nos preguntan cuál está pendiente de la
línea que contiene estos puntos pausa
este vídeo y trata de resolverlo por tu
cuenta
antes de hacerlo juntos muy bien ahora
hagamos dos juntos y recordemos que es
la pendiente la pendiente es igual al
cambio en g esta es la letra y delta
parece un triángulo pero es una
abreviatura del cambio en g sobre el
cambio en x algunas veces lo verás
escrito como ye 2 menos de 1 sobre x 2 -
x 1 donde podrías ver a x1 y uno como
punto de inicio y x2 ye 2 como punto
final así que escojamos dos pares de xy
y podemos elegir cualquiera si suponemos
que realmente están describiendo una
línea elijamos los dos primeros digamos
que este es nuestro punto de inicio y
este es nuestro punto final entonces
cuál es nuestro cambio en x aquí vamos
de 2 a 3 así que nuestro cambio en x es
igual a tres menos 2 que es igual a 1 y
puedes ver que de 2 a 3 sólo está
sumando 1
y cuál es nuestro cambio en nuestro
cambio en que es nuestra ya final
1 - nuestra inicial 4 que es igual a
menos 3 y no tenías que hacer esas
operaciones habrías podido ver que para
ir de 2 a 3 sumas 1 y para ir de 4 a 1
debes restar 3 aquí tenemos toda la
información que necesitamos cuánto es el
cambio en g sobre el cambio en x bueno
nuestro cambio en g
es menos 3 y nuestro cambio en x es 1
entonces nuestra pendiente es negativa 3
dividido entre 1 es igual a menos 3
hagamos otro ejemplo aquí nos preguntan
cuál es la pendiente de la línea que
contiene estos puntos pausa el vídeo
nuevamente y trata de resolverlo muy
bien recuerda la pendiente es igual al
cambio en g sobre el cambio en x y
podríamos elegir cualquiera de estos
pares para resolverlo si suponemos que
esto realmente es una línea bueno solo
por variar vamos a escoger estos dos
pares de en medio
entonces cuál es nuestro cambio en x
para pasar de 1 a 5 sumamos 4 y cuál es
nuestro cambio en g para pasar de 7 a 13
sumamos 6 entonces nuestro cambio en 6 y
nuestro cambio en x es 4 y tengo los
signos correctos en ambos casos es
positivo cuando x aumenta que también
aumenta así que nuestra pendiente es
igual a 6 cuartos y podríamos describir
esto tanto el 6 como el 4 son divisibles
entre 2 entonces dividimos el numerador
y el denominador entre 2 y obtenemos 3
medios y hemos terminado